take a chill pill melt some metal in the
palm of your hand and enter doormat
because loot is back cook your morning
eggs outside with the help of sole
source a device that allows you to
harness the sun's energy to cook
anything you want from fried eggs to
steaks without any outside power source
you can even cook a hamburger shaped
like a hot dog or just eat a boatload of
salad of course you're also new your
morning coffee wait no I guess you won't
grumpycat no bug if you just need to
power your phone outside you can use
this power pot thermoelectric generator
just boil water inside the pot and use
the heat to generate enough electricity
to power your phone in the same amount
of time as a conventional outlet this
sort of thing would be great for the
zombie apocalypse which you can join in
by outfitting yourself with shirts from
electric zombie with zombie road
warriors and even zombie shirts for your
dog but until the apocalypse you'll
still have to go to work so keep the
party going from last night with this
hypno cube for your desk it's a 3d
animated display of lights that will
help you relax by staring deep into its
hypnotic glow to keep things hidden at
the workplace just throw them away into
your dumpster keepsake box that looks
almost as fly as your rainbow keyboard
or your interactive ferrofluid sculpture
deemed the lava lamp of the 21st century
instead of a desk maybe you should work
off this alien table or just take a nap
in your Viking ship bed where some
custom shoes from more than art to wear
calm that include air jordan poison dart
frog shoes and double happiness or
customize your own cardboard robot arms
with this do-it-yourself kit over at
Etsy that has everything you'll need to
finally have giant cardboard arms pigeon
mask eye pong is a ping pong training
buddy that will help improve your skills
it has the ability to oscillate and
create topspin on the ball preparing you
to school your friends for the first
time in potentially last time ever two
Romanian bear skeletons are being sold
for $85,000 I found them on this
incredible
called tell me where on earth calm that
not only has rare bear fossils for sale
but all kinds of oddities such as moose
poop earrings african meteorite
fragments or the largest cave bear skull
wait what it's sold if you don't want
the real thing just buy some of these
anatomically correct and to scale
dinosaurs carved by Galileo Hernandez
Nunez at gene models calm but in order
to buy any of this stuff you could use
some cold hard cash or one of the ten
credit cards the obtain iam wallet can
hold recently backed on Kickstarter
these wallets are made to be durable
small and handsome holding as much as a
normal wallet without the chance of it
stretching out losing your stuff or
getting damaged look cool with your new
wallet but smart with your classic books
tablet cover available in the Great
Gatsby Alice in Wonderland and great
expectations and now it's time to hit
the eject button light switch and as
always thanks for watching
I'll get you
you